whether by tram train
or bus
over the next three months journeys with
these are much cheaper
for ten dollars or nine euros a month
passengers can now get unlimited local
and regional travel around the country
we have prepared for japan as good as
possible
for example with additional trains 250
trains every day
in our networks in germany
and we have
additional
person staff on the trains and also in
the railway station so we try the best
to be prepared
at a time when inflation is higher than
it has been for a long time ministers
hope this policy will ease some of the
financial pain caused by rising prices
this is what the passenger gets for
their nine euros a ticket to ride
anywhere in this country which can be
bought in the paper version or on a
smartphone armed with one of these
theoretically i can take most of the
trains trams or buses that stop at this
station but most people who use this are
likely to be commuters
so what do they make of it
i just bought it it's great because i
used to pay 86 and now it's nine and i
have to go to work every day so it was
big expense
i use public transport a lot in
different cities munich cologne berlin
so it's very convenient
by making public transport much more
affordable if only for three months this
is a green policy so the theory goes
but some people say it doesn't go far
enough we need to invest a lot more
especially in our rail systems and
that's not something that you can do
overnight uh it's also not something
that is done in three months so we need
more trains we need longer trains we
need uh
to build more train tracks
we need more buses these are all things
that take take time
the cheaper season ticket has been
introduced to coincide with a cut in
fuel costs for motorists the price of
petrol at the pump has risen sharply
since the war in ukraine at first glance
on wednesday prices do seem now to be
dropping
so taken together the politicians in
charge believe what they're introducing
will make a difference the next three
months will tell us whether most germans
agree
donna kane al jazeera berlin